the police departments in New York City
and Los Angeles are monitoring
developments in the Middle East for any
potential threats in this country CBS
News senior national security
contributor and former acting and deputy
CIA director Michael Morell joins us
Michael welcome again good morning
Michael
both former presidents George W Bush and
Obama reportedly rejected in targeting
soleimani in the past fearing it could
lead to war but we heard the defense
secretary say the game has changed how
significant is this radical shift in
strategy so Anthony here's here's the
balance Qasem Soleimani was an evil
genius
he had a lot of American blood on his
hands he was the mastermind behind
Iranian malign behavior in the region
the world is a better place without him
the problem is that comes at a very high
cost number one there will be dead
Americans dead civilian Americans as a
result of this possibly over the next
few days in any place where Iran has its
proxies Iraq is the most likely place
but also Lebanon Bahrain other places in
the Middle East number two this sets a
precedent Anthony that that senior
officials are fair game
in this hybrid not yet at war kind of
scenario that we're in with Iran and
that's a dangerous precedent to set
number three this is actually going to
enable the hardliners strengthen the
hardliners in Iran as we heard earlier
Qasem Soleimani extremely popular in
Iran and that is going to actually
strengthen those people who follow him
and lastly I think we've now ended any
hope of keeping Iraq out of Iran's arms
I think we're gonna see the Iranian
parliament vote very shortly possibly as
early as today to send American troops
home
so yes it's good that he's gone but it
comes in an extraordinarily high price
and that's why the Bush administration
and the Obama administration chose not
to do something like this Michael how do
you think Iran is specifically likely to
respond
so I think it depends I think if they
think about it rationally they will not
conduct a military strike on US military
forces in the region because they're
gonna lose that battle I think what the
Iranians are gonna do is they're gonna
turn their proxies loose throughout the
region to go after civilians and at a
time and place of their choosing they're
gonna conduct a terrorist strike that
kills a senior American official and
that could be anywhere in the world the
Iranians and Lebanese Hezbollah their
their main ally have contingency plans
on the books for such terrorist attacks
so such a terrorist attack could occur
soon Mike when you say and it's bracing
to hear you say that there will be dead
Americans including civilians in this
response from Iran and it could be
anywhere in the world that includes the
United States yes it does how might that
unfold so as I said Lebanese Hezbollah
which is one of you know their closest
allies has contingency plans and those
into include contingency plans in the
United States against us targets do we
know anything about who might replace
soleimani there's the old adage about
the devil you know and the devil you
don't so there is some there is some
chatter on social media about the
Iranians having already announced his
successor it's his deputy it's his
long-time deputy of 22 years same
philosophy same ideology not the same
charisma but the same approach so I
don't think we're gonna see a change in
Iranian behavior as a result of Qasem
Soleimani death right Michael Morell
fors thank you
you